comenzamos reporteros de france 24
gracias por estar con nosotros en el
siguiente reportaje veremos los detalles
de la millonaria operación words speed e
impulsada por el entonces presidente de
eeuu donald trump para lograr una vacuna
contra el coi 19 antes que el resto del
mundo la campaña lanzada en diciembre
esperaba vacunar a 20 millones de
personas antes del primero de enero de
2021 pero los resultados no fueron así
para esa fecha sólo se había alcanzado
el 25 por ciento de la meta original
recordemos que fue tron quien le restó
importancia a la gravedad del virus y
ridiculizó a los rivales que llevaban
mascarilla
hasta que el mismo se contagio del virus
matthew mama es el corresponsal en
washington de nuestra cadena en francés
y nos acompaña en esta emisión más yo
gracias por estar con nosotros y qué
significa esta operación millonaria
bueno nuestra generación debe recordar
la serie viaje a las estrellas star trek
jungle operación
antillas state wars pit significa
velocidad de la luz y tussam plomos y
test de la línea s ideó el nombre de
esta operación se tomó prestado de la
famosa serie pero se ha puesto en su
contra porque la principal queja que los
norteamericanos tienen contra esta
enorme campaña de vacunación es la lenta
que ha demostrado ser un salón que no ha
alcanzado sus propósitos y mientras
hablamos sólo ha logrado una cuarta
parte de sus objetivos como un tablón
gracias maestro invitados entonces a ver
el siguiente reportaje
[Música]
en temas políticos
estamos listos y estamos haciendo un
excelente trabajo saldrá bien estén
tranquilos
no subestimen este virus
[Música]
y le ordenamos a los habitantes del
estado que se queden en su casa emitirá
una orden ejecutiva pidiéndole a los
habitantes de florida de limitar sus
movimientos y toda interacción
emitiremos una orden ejecutiva el estado
de nueva york está en pausa
no hay una nación que haya estado y que
esté más determinada distribuir vacunas
en todo el mundo si no hay garantía de
que tengamos una vacuna segura y eficaz
pero somos optimistas
stec haga su trabajo señor presidente
habremos fabricado al menos 100 millones
de vacunas antes del final de año
base naval de norfolk virginia es aquí
donde la idea es navy la marina más
poderosa del mundo alberga sus
infraestructuras más importantes
el hospital militar de portsmouth está
hecho para atender hasta seis mil
heridos de guerra de manera simultánea
en ella sostenido
entonces cuando donald trump le declaró
la guerra al cob y 19 de manera muy
natural el ejército estadounidense se
sitúa en primera línea
la mañana del 15 de diciembre la agencia
estadounidense del medicamento autorizó
la distribución de la primera vacuna
eficaz contra el virus para los
militares no hay tiempo que perder y las
órdenes son claras
es el comienzo de la operación word
speech la mayor campaña de vacunación
organizada en toda la historia de eeuu
y perdidos
sí no
las preciadas dosis llegaron en la noche
para ser recibidas de manera prioritaria
por el personal médico
que constituye la primera línea de
defensa contra la pandemia
a su vez médicos y enfermeras pronto
podrán vacunar en masa a sus
conciudadanos
y sé que no se corren riesgos recibiendo
esta vacuna se comprobó que es eficaz
después de estudios preliminares
entonces confío
y creo que estar enferma de covite es
mucho más peligroso que cualquier
reacción alérgica posible y espero que
gracias a esta vacuna estemos más
protegidos hacia el final del año
tanto para estos militares como para la
aplastante mayoría de la opinión pública
estadounidense la fiabilidad de las
vacunas fácil variante que luego moderna
no deja dudas para ellos la operación
world speed es el único medio para
liberar el país de la pandemia
y reducir así la cantidad de muertes la
'operación war is speed nos concierne
directamente pues ahora tenemos acceso a
la vacuna que tratamos de administrarle
a la mayor cantidad de personas lo más
rápido posible y sin correr riesgos
hemos tenido algunas pandemias en estos
últimos años
evo la cica y ahora tenemos el cob y
debemos prepararnos para cuando esto
vuelva a ocurrir y aprender de lo que
pasó así la próxima vez seremos más
veloces y al ver la rapidez con la que
llegaron estas vacunas si funcionan bien
eso significa que seguramente seremos
más eficaces
en washington la experiencia de los
militares en el dominio de la gestión de
crisis no se le escapó a la
administración
la epidemia inmediatamente se convirtió
en crisis económica y en crisis política
la casablanca criticada por sin acción
se demoró meses en entender la gravedad
del fenómeno
ah
sin embargo en plena campaña
presidencial el lanzamiento de la
operación worlds beat terminó por
convertirse uno de los principales
pilares de la comunicación de donald
trump
dos prazeres of the united states de
james bond
quiero darle la bienvenida al médico a
los científicos a los representantes de
la industria y a la administración de
esta operación histórica la operación
web speed esto ha sido una gran aventura
para todos nosotros y es un inmenso
éxito la vacuna genérica se produjo en
menos de nueve meses en nombre de toda
la nación le agradezco a todos los que
están presentes hoy y a los que se
involucraron en este extraordinario
proyecto estadounidense moncef es la wii
donde estamos ser muchas gracias y un
buen trabajo
[Aplausos]
dos de las vacunas son 100 eficaces
contra los síntomas graves y las dos
también son eficaces para las personas
mayores de 65 años
hasta la aparición de un virus llamado
con 1.019 el doctor mons ejes la win era
un científico que pasaba desapercibido
sólo era conocido en el microcosmos de
los epidemiólogos como uno de los
mejores de su especialidad
asociar al ejército a la operación fue
su idea desde hace meses este
estadounidense de origen marroquí
prepara un secreto la llegada de la
vacuna
[Música]
para moncef es la wing la receta simple
la operación sólo puede lograrse si es
dirigida por científicos planificada por
militares y puesta en marcha por los
mejores oficiales de logística todo el
conjunto lo más alejado posible de las
presiones políticas y mediáticas que
llegan de todas partes los cuales que
sabe access porque aceptó la petición de
donald trump de participar en esta
aventura a pesar de mi reticencia a
trabajar con esta administración con la
cual no estoy para nada de acuerdo
decidí que era mucho más importante
actuar al descubrimiento y al desarrollo
y acelerar el proceso que llevaría a la
vacuna
realmente estaba muy muy preocupado y
sigo estando preocupado por la
politización que hubo alrededor del
descubrimiento de la vacuna y en
realidad eso creó una atención y una
pérdida de confianza en general porque
el trabajo científico riguroso que se
hizo se confundió con las retóricas
políticas de las dos partes
[Música]
una parte decía que no era probable que
no se podía hacer que debía haber algo
sospechoso y la otra decía que se haría
antes de las elecciones
me parece que ambas se equivocaron
asustaron a la población mientras que el
trabajo que nosotros llevamos a cabo fue
absolutamente científico riguroso y se
basó sobre los datos
de batalla política sobre un fondo de
pandemia el peor escenario para un
investigador
espero que la gente tenga rápidamente la
oportunidad de escuchar a las personas
en quienes confían y espero llegar a la
conclusión de que estas vacunas son
seguras y que nos ayudarán a regresar a
nuestra vida normal
sin embargo un mes después del
lanzamiento de la operación y a pesar de
la movilización de los gigantes de la
logística los resultados no están a la
altura
la administración trampa había prometido
20 millones de vacunados antes del
primero de enero no obstante sólo se ha
logrado el 25 por ciento del objetivo
aún así se ha consagrado 10 mil millones
de dólares a la operación
de la cual el transportador más célebre
del mundo federal de express se encarga
de una parte significativa
se transportan por camión por avión se
cargan y se empacan
la empresa que controla cuidadosamente
su comunicación rechazó todas nuestras
solicitudes de grabación y entrevistas
estas imágenes fueron brindadas por su
servicio de comunicación estamos a cargo
de millones de vacunas todos los años y
trabajamos con paquetes que es necesario
mantener a cierta temperatura todos los
días las industrias que producen la
vacuna y las que la distribuyen ya son
nuestros clientes los conocemos
conocemos su mercado por eso el gobierno
nos solicitó porque tenemos los
conocimientos y la red necesaria para
realizar esta operación no decidimos
quién recibe primero la vacuna el
trabajo que nos corresponde es
asegurarnos que lleguen a su destino y
nuestro objetivo es enviar estas vacunas
contra el coi 19 a las comunidades que
lo necesitan lo más rápido posible y en
las mejores condiciones
lo más rápido posible sin embargo en
baltimore maryland una de las ciudades
más afectadas por la pandemia hay más de
tres semanas después de la aprobación de
las vacunas algunos centros de
vacunación siguen esperando las
preciadas dosis en enero mientras la
cifra de muertos alcanzaba a los 4.000
diarios el cuerpo médico de baltimore
sigue teniendo que cuidar a los enfermos
pero sin poderlos vacunar
y aquí realizamos perfusión es de
anticuerpos monoclonales que no son
vacunas pero si alguien está enfermo de
kobe de este tratamiento debería reducir
sus posibilidades de hospitalizaciones
eso es lo que hacemos aquí porque
todavía no somos un lugar de vacunación
y addax insight
retraso sin explicación que terminan por
sembrar la duda entre la población de
ocumare cuando sea posible pero por
ahora quiero saber primero si hay
efectos secundarios varias empresas
ofrecen una vacuna estoy esperando a ver
cómo reacciona la población con el
palacio del congreso de baltimore ahora
se convirtió en el mayor centro de
cuidados contra el hobbit en maryland
según las autoridades del estado que no
nos autoriza en el ingreso al edificio
todo está listo pero muy a pesar de este
médico la vacuna todavía no ha llegado
hoy es un buen día pero nos espera un
invierno difícil todos los modelos
muestran que la situación va a empeorar
tan solo en maryland las camas de los
hospitales ocupadas son tantas o incluso
más que las que había en abril y mayo
[Música]
entre sus promesas de campaña de donald
trump juraba que las vacunas convertiría
la pandemia en un mal recuerdo en dos o
tres meses
a mediados de enero mientras el
ministerio de salud anunció 500 mil
vacunados por día estados unidos no
espera poder vencer el virus antes del
verano de 2021 como muy pronto
regresamos con máxima va uno de los
autores del reportaje que ustedes acaban
de ver y le pregunto cómo se ha
desarrollado esta operación millonaria
en este momento el departamento de salud
de eeuu ha reportado que 10 millones de
personas han sido vacunadas cuál es la
historia detrás de esto
envía tus amores con las promesas y los
objetivos establecidos por trump por su
séquito y por el equipo de la operación
guard speed no han sido cumplidos y
subjefes qt y fabián whiplash aunque
debemos poner estas promesas en contexto
fueron hechas durante la campaña
presidencial lo que tuvo una influencia
decisiva en las comunicaciones
realizadas alrededor de la operación de
ese tope acción una botón de unión luego
tortas
en el reportaje escuchamos al doctora
montse es la wii condenar como el clima
electoral distorsiona el trabajo de
científicos coordinadores y el personal
militar detrás de la operación
de mille y también europeo acciones que
este acto básico jordi hoy dependiendo
de la región solamente entre el 10% y el
25% de los objetivos han sido alcanzados
si dejas que un profesional decente y
quieta y por tomate los trabajadores de
la salud serían los primeros en ser
vacunados aparentemente no lo han sido y
con esta condición un gran despliegue
para el público en general no puede
hacerse capa de machismo
entre los seguidores están muchos dicen
que el coi 19 es una farsa y se rehúsan
a usar mascarillas como esto afecta a la
situación mater
y sabemos lo suficiente para decir que
la negativa a usar mascarilla ha tenido
serias consecuencias en las áreas en
donde esta es una práctica común
achicoria move pong y un post en
particular el centro de los estados
unidos en donde trump tuvo la mayoría de
los votantes y donde las cifras del
virus son las más desastrosas hay un
vínculo directo de causa y efecto
incluso de efecto limón gb la historia
juzgará el discurso de trump y su manera
ligera de tratar el virus o donald trump
y la ley arte y fue el día de al menos
al principio después de un giro que el
reportaje resalta claramente estudio un
don y nieto álex también hubo un cambio
en la estrategia de comunicación pero
esta nueva estrategia creó promesas
imposibles odiamos al short y deformes
aceptó y realista
si esta operación funciona será gracias
a trump o a pesar de trump que tanto le
corresponde al expresidente o al
personal médico que tanto ridiculizó
y la historia lo dirá lo que sabemos es
que la sociedad norteamericana y el
mundo entero se las deben a la comunidad
científica la cual realizó un milagro
produciendo una vacuna en menos de nueve
meses superando todas las expectativas
también sabemos que las comunicaciones
de donald trump han sido desastrosas y
tomará tiempo digerir y entender en
detalle cuáles políticas fueron
promulgadas por la administración y la
casa blanca y descifrar si la operación
wardbase funcionará y si se propaga si
un huésped ay el mono aunque será
difícil tener números específicos antes
de la primavera o el verano conjunto en
donde las autoridades esperan al menos
haber debilitado la pandemia y quien
espera jugar para disparar me sumo a ese
estuve la condena
gracias a máxima va por acompañarnos en
la emisión de este reportaje a ustedes
también gracias por estar con nosotros y
recuerde que puede ingresar a nuestra
página web france24 puntocom para ver
este y los anteriores reportajes hasta
la próxima semana
[Música]